how was special to Kobe as a teammate as
a man and as a friend
Pablo
Kobe predicted you and he would be
together in the rafters
Vanessa Bryant returns to the Lakers
Arena to honor her late husband Kobe
Bryant's close friend and teammate Pau
Gasol I miss him so much like many of us
do I love him I wish he was here with
Gigi I really do it's Vanessa's First
Time In the Venue since February 24th
2020 the day of Kobe and their daughter
Gianna's memorial service
we love and miss you boo-boo and Gigi it
was an emotional night in the house of
purple and gold as the Lakers retired
the Spanish basketball stars number 16
Jersey Powell visibly Interiors as his
hung next to Kobe's
[Applause]
Vanessa made a rare appearance to share
a special moment with him
it is my honor to introduce my dear
friend pal tonight here's a little video
I want you to watch there's no debate I
mean how when he retires he will have
his number in the Raptors next to mine
the reality is I don't win those
championships without pal see you have a
lady that have those two championships
without having so we know that everybody
knows that and I really look forward to
the day when he's there giving his at
that Center
of all the fans who have supported them
over the years so it's going to be
awesome tonight
Kobe and pal had a tight Bond on and off
the court
we're very very close and I'm very happy
for him that he's playing well the pair
played Seven Seasons together taking
home two championship trophies as
teammates
[Applause]
Kobe retired from the NBA in 2016 with
tragedy striking just four years later
when the basketball Pro Gigi and seven
others died in a helicopter crash I
still didn't want to believe it you
still thought that Kobe
could have gotten out of that action by
his own feet you know he was that
Invincible we wanted to be close to
Vanessa and the kids being there for him
as much as possible and the Gasol family
has been there for the Bryants both
families continue to share special
moments together
I'm gonna drop my phone ready yep set go
one two three
it's a bond so special Powell and his
wife Catherine named their daughter in
honor of Gianna my daughter's full name
is Elizabeth Gianna Gasol to have
Gianna's name remembering her and having
her present it represents so much
I'm just gonna try to be a good father
to my daughter a good uncle to his
daughters
boom
good job 90. a good brother to his wife
and that's why it's no surprise Vanessa
being there for pal in his big night
means so much to him
I think you are here in the building
thank you for being here I love you
sister I'm proud to be your brother I'm
proud to be an uncle to your lovely
girls
but I can't go on without talking about
the person in the face that I don't see
uh the brother that elevated me inspired
me challenged me to be a better player
just to be a better man overall but I
think you'll be proud
and he was looking forward to this
moment so
I love you brother
[Music]